online now
hello my name is bas dries and the chief
technology officer al
mm as in the netherlands and very yeti
for this opportunity to tell you will
ever bed where the work within it meters
in twente de vel de best
pension models for researchers to help
them  develop and new thermal and if
then the counts wanted built they had
company we mineral surprise here
have order in lead in the dutch
we will fight and down washington and in
tokyo and providing sites
how to heroin mission and that's the
fourth dedicated  to provide
researchers with the best show and order
models to enable them to develop the
new management for the of the first
century and why if i sweat it in
so drug development pipeline is canary
in the picnic or jesus so
the blade tools for powerscreen
secondary jump  and where or something
the tax and safety related always at the
outpatient clinic to fall the block
pipeline and
really want to offer researchers what else is there
tomorrow  and chip technology
way to better capture the thin finn de
thai better capture the differences
between passions and all but really
limiting the complexities of tissue ssd
years in the dantians not like course and
green hoop der beek gap between
the conventional to the cell culture
or animal models  and is doing rush
action in the boy body and my bridges
and go app so that
archives research is much more
products and and lauren nevels as to make
better decisions in what routers
how you want your cat chair in the rats
willem a pipeline
and have a good time  the clinic and
prevent them from all i slack letter
in the pipeline
and wit just about world we have in
both your projects models but also to be
able to generate tools the allah and the
caravan to understanding of intricate
beziers mechanism minutes covers of
effect continue
charlie  lacking in the conventional ways
of doing in vitro research and one of
them is of hive nobody the stick with
young fish
whole  al if the old complex it's in
under
mate that you have to because in the issue
what's simple in up boy and the
soften see that all of those test or
that I've walked worn convex the
boy situation will feed you and choked
boy with  lord ions
there other aspects that that that mean
i think you're really completed your
rescue and well represented at mobile or
the in vivo situation and that's not
oh i as yourself in july you need that by
mixing act
mixing or even how you  medical school
makes you do become collagen
and how do you not think the combine at
zero bosvelt fireplace in the trie dimension
of setting to recapture
the de complex architects of tissues in
the body and and other very your plate and
effectiveness is wesley relation how
lovely there is  a develop horse or
door response to certain sting like of
tissues in van inter coppard in heaven
when in be able to make decisions in the
site and paints a simple year in the
house and bipod their marcels in the
co  ntinue sheer harassment
setting week and belt providers even wit
this my fire fire
that they also experience in the body and
data allow yourself or a respond to
trunks we vote where he becomes your the
groin aspects and they would your
in the house and so  no one becomes roots
we didn't have we do it or using the
mood simplify platform
figurative rattan look taste the
past for every suffering
there is baie that is you just a creative
workplace the magic is in the bottom zo
if you look at the bottom of this paper
plate
you see her channels linking
often up together and it in box and
us back who
noise high level of control everywhere
easy with interest with some cells it
wat my garden and then like toe bilt
de bilt wishes everyone can wat setting
les en hoe die six  killer 1000 x is
here and the first is it's just about have a
pointless and us will fresh core technology
allows was to build a tissue en vlieland
mn apps vs die technology in it is
me used to h  eaven and earth on the vide
stems into the dot com partners
so you have counter is movisie became in
summary on ipad
the yellow religion and into the taste
find channels the runner zipper
smashing at the bottom or not mike
tell us are you wet member and senseless
whatsoever justice symbol rate which om
the bottom of this chamber and early
pills forces d prevent that gel from
flow into the entire my guling
network you have to get used to usable what limited
to there someone who self send that
self and that and
and xlii technology  shows the main story
alone on the bed him so i know your good
look and a simple standard for you for
well plate
do you flip it over you can see with in
this case the stand for well a link up
together to form country sex tips
becomes something  or the dessert our own
function the first of them is not bells
and george al in so with using normal
conventional pirates
you can piper in wiper rather for such a
book all and material mix do it like this
and that a lines with a rich with the
holiday show the force was behind the
blue chelsea seem you can ipad
media in the other colleague service
and gloom and that must flo and mo spy george
every apartment of it to bestow well
into the for the
the park does service roots and us
not that where
action yo experts that deforms so the
fish how that changed in the gel
want that provider so far and his
oxygen found
perfusion flow double and form complex
freelance inspectors and
and ficus i lesbos him  fly well play
you can just i deceive this led display in any
of the court and many in line
in this case the losers my
hide or so he content microscope
and other device bios
to put the image of the chips in one
place and really  do
and and counter what's going on in showbox
individual coaches who sat there vanessa
according to all or five soft tissue culture of
course a goal in lead
channels that all those de toe self daimler
the motive and everything still very  what flow
are you with the medium pless of the stack
and in the gate well
was confusion nucleus and occasionally the
tissue paper capsule in us the
place du dan juice building for the
projection oh
patient not place in the split to
chop platform the  tales mango chips en
place at form a fishing rod n minus the
along the link bouncer
i want a wide of siege field become the
rockwell
have for singing head in the ditch asked the
matrix and off 3 bad gets close to
i want to wake up with it  platform
flash on sit still the other way
so the flow versus and you maintain and
continuous flow
so on to the tips in parallel we have that
i do that to choose and pancetta
another one touch of having place became
right for a for well format then of
quiet you forever is that slit
sara's eyes were walking with moment cloud there
such because oil for imaging what us so
for loading handling her box in your
place dear think that completely auto along
search bent so we are  op je sleigh
wheel comments
halloween or or automation loading
en for van julia toe plug became flesh
or joosten show band
review he prefer station a lot
to perform the perm and sorry german is tired of
pottery and on level or this in
theory that pink u  can your
with those
with a stiff or prize would [ __ ]
fill the room because who wins tour is
in the tielt soon she becomes see on this
life around the top is a maximum projection
or in network of ipads and iphones
i always have in fact york  and openness
and
xlii pig now in the means that emotion or
a confocal
imaging three specs from young jury see
it's so i feel three dimensional
network net form flow from the icm
and the this wearing affect the level of
interaction between your nose and
moreover in the  button panel will i have
it kathleen you don't know that i
already such a look at the activity of the
even so that the beek in frieze in
surprising that you just will papa was xlii
the reaction of
na  ar us a figure using compound
so off starting once more so here that so
many oh level
tv tip dan's activity m ip address
i think my treasure is an active
noise and once you
exposen to date
lo and behold jane a campaign see  you that all
fans of a the light up and and donk
risi and this is the right version
simpoints ramps of how you can use in
this case from the authorized even
program in a three-dimensional never
look at their protein expression
wat orzo
arne to do  more she became of his
essays in this case
fantastic
another me simple and was some of
recently waldeck new
in nepal we have gone hans
clevers from direct institute in lead
where they aren't you get where they use
the order beautiful technology and in  the ferry
quite a namely toe
toemai never heard french neck of a
dun and i don't pretend snack ups and downs
of became how i know things like a
looping for
corn test the effectiveness of bells
of net
snake venom  and motivates was who
muscle cells gave it to him in infusion
log n o p and actually
to the tops you functional style
dress noble stuff like the muscle cells
and in the button to panels
this rig and cäcilie
so i think if you guys give me things and stuff
who likes with the top movie
would mean panel in this will show
you the activity of the myo chups in
response to comic con so so lisa may
trigger herself a and what you see is
well he wants to start bones movie watch
you see the hard way and  eating do
they have the des who is there the mast or even
the word weed it with snake venom with
every politician live
so trigger that should normal you
activate
my youtube in the mass mobile me in
the competition in effects and how we this
is wide of  is in operation with
this time of innovative meat of using
are never technology and free the
cell culture and
very happy to pad is he himself so
her digital concepcion you the hurricane a
place to live with people their stoe  len and
snacks how singer and sociology of and
filled the gel walk takes for
reviews and what already so far behind you a
system that allows you will get more
creativity and note it my
flexibility that ever and on seems real
scary and best get first  i said it will be
a 1 in private security in tool
don't you do nothing for it freelance
anything about life medium long
played with the shell and the then
flanking loan to you for views and
the fun and do some wild marie for
cooking or something
one x apple the millionth freelance
at is finished in in the four or then further temse
and in looking do you have fact of flow
long 5 tools such as buzzing and who sie
in time
sensitive and a what food for look at
the wrist  have that people mamma mia
parties ribbon in inspector i am further
cremselen is that it is very difficult to
get to get right to go into and can in
interbank became the cancer and you're
looking have okay so what that it is not that
i do that you  sure that this f  ans i need
a float was already to boring
the
along fact tumor projection
provide much more reviews and as a
true rituals him even though officers that
int i get a complete fm
[Music]
pino time and our jean fact between is
the bygone so for singing
interstitial flow
itself free with the fish most bad with
mornings and in showers
professionals and transporter french and
it in suze's place president reports
expression and and that not that six
new york city so defective then
does this more real finality
mix ben nicky even  more more effected
by treatment webcam sit and sit those
bizarre samples of the same day as there are in
tree
by spending even insiders amateur
sexy you second know how you user bottle of
private and safe and then my
king is
key so in that case investors
barricades even  in the gel with must
shell and how i myself in the puget sound
and really air technology and scarf in the
creamy and you have to start and pagel
education
otherlecht  who ipad meanwhile mike oil
for himself suspension and who takes
place
simply signs then decide to let gravity
your hero screen and te site have jente gel
and them was me start per view are even
grow and into a few wat is so lord of
the wright the  partner loops and 10,000
shell and all let you really he
shoot shape or even and with interface
between the gel and the self with really
just tell myself further numbers of
fillers of a blocking
actions on this issue very interesting
compartment
je kan look at the transporter  barrier becomes
bold effects cross the seller's to
us about decay in the migration or even
i was so tired lucy steele perdition and
applications dieser from texas af
pokémon google queen in the version sat
still
principle colleagues and af wat me to you
seen ice je violin de  features you'd
expect to boot sites and
do you can you fix it
earlier witzel along what or something i'm luc
i do be boring and so the best
self-service station with you know and in this
case now full of hope in using have a video
tomorrow nights tufan tufan as many and every
six and source to them out of doors
for the knights crow them into actual
wrote and the benefit of time is that the
comics different front and the back of den
berg  and phil attached to and do the in
an outlet wel school
you combine their very nicely
file typically 11 plus models of
self care
or organic 30 kilos there just god me
net is that an arm ball will your oil have
access to the
basil slide because we  could
even wave or even in this case was not in good
take those even a capsule image form
how you whiskey i have the best of both
worlds to china is the using the organ
ever workflow that allows you to have
access to passion the life it issues
and not ply and expansion so even of
passions and
becomes mission is that i become an xlii look and
the weakened lips that in shed new
model and with and and and real-time stijn
waifs of kind battle on sunday
sessions and other and o  ther a lecture
pray for it is then
by hands part of group
using i work nobody all at all the
mobile the one commerce
so far by suffocation for the cats
with your ball
sharer in able to manage the trucks my
google by combining powders 15 and the
filium
in a freelance setup and
it was white infusion that self
start push in the pot there is already
basil him separate components and
really started to form more and more from
their own michael
really with us you have to go in the bar and
get tired sexy  family mouse find the man
suspense 3 means figures
time
switches wet soft life lock
weaponize be what what witch lisa is that
a good lee also ate us
and there induction all energy seen at
invented essence my
with so mode mole and and taking
screen  from people with members still
auditing and once you
i slept reviews dude and merlyn modis
formulas mohammed de sira van de sees
this letter party for baby and lithium
alice i walked  do you see that expo sing
when the three screen your or a dynamic
is in the formulas mobile wallet your
hair movie of hell typical our
management maintain and eyes belgium
function of the sends a loss and
very creative ways to doing that so
close to the mac  is there action king
in guys
and and and and tryin to get tools the mode
better understand escape for our
product
the effect rhythms on jotham the fnp
upside down bottles and then i know my
using
confectionery by using stil xlii very simple
even what  extreme the robust and
scalable
watched even in technobabble people
know simple setup
who builds you mix awarded a gel and
the lions leverage the swans was
actually not so much to go into the
tales with must with a long toe tube
what do you do on it  more larger scale riso
this is of detail populist already some
years ago
what poverty be surprised the silence knew
to the section the largest order a chip
also
it is that ermengarde to see here is e  and
tip of time point of screen and jumped
up and the caller integrity or that success
da in school on is cash and you
can be very painful
floor
prime and i was concentrations keep that
quiet for you from quantico
intervention and you will controller me
even a little longer to live strings not
if your intention recently started to if
there is something new in heeg fr en format
so review it interest in
looking at calling function around your buttocks
psv van transport and parties cross eco
device and where you really want to be in
a moral and a warm for the yes
just in my free man still
and were yes culture
just in the presence of a museum with
out and you'll be him and brain because
that in the way to steal buyer should ek
design a and many  promises shell for you
can simply save by pl-t side i on the plus
come home and do the research
esmond the sword inc is a ladder
melancholy
who's been tryin to make this research and
the retail and accessible to
i worth  honor clot
den mountain of course some of these from the
driver i look at evision camp to that
you have to do in his or with your and 4 seater
my tent and content in south or the tour
for third djuz' cold we those so on the
corrida
you  toe xlii immetje and is so hot
that offers or so traditionally but
there is of course and this body of mr
out there were no use
nice jacket
to be able to compare
to a decade for boy he wanted to
peer mega man can be violin excorcism
measurements what what we then some hours
in your system if not then that the man
projection lee went out and develop one
with my instrument to be you  what it is
and take that thing away
people walk at this movie
we have small instrument time say this
is basically the footprint over
fireplace and judith in a word for
electro with you have to go under plate and sit
it was a member you click to the people
with  j  onathan porridge and so right angle
invoices laptop directly to drive the
blades with electronic and so and so
vial with each of it rotates one in
frequency sweet to perform in peter
spectroscopy
the grass youtube so in mango wood
one-click you measure especially on it
so all foster nature of ajax
fact if the gel is the electrical
connector tips on those shows and it allows you
to their very fast a temporary
feedback to the helping of you want
those on those shows and if there per
milliliter being
nice safety net a boy
Deze de comes out of this can also the
varied and see you can use it to men
too great or chose to see when these
already for your comic con super
intervention for any other research
to do with your man
what you can ofzo of course directly
look  at effect des expos it sometimes even
you will do the power tool
real time and highly carolina
measurements in in noise scalable
ow underskirt and eat up
[Music]
roy the start of views and looked up when
they are sports lifestyle tips in
and we love the good idea that it
spreads and the wisest beautiful system
but we should be able to
move once and want to wall tattoo
our use the best self scout became so
and similar to the knee workshop before
and we'  ve 10 either
plying so a rational or taking
even of come tomorrow moyens the
immediately about aspects of the of the tation
that the order mouth gets out of
and take them out of that circle
through the woods know modality where you
only access to the  outside of the or the
order nights
technically high quality even and put
them into a little bit more accessible
format attend and really sweet
in the organ or one
and what we think what we started with that
livergy
is 13 can maintain this de physiology of
die even so
use the cells to mobile offer
so at by taking jokes peking column
organ ever proves shoots
cussing and marley or triggering and itv
night by exponents site guys this book
week and reeleezee
the responses yet yo  u would expect
if not and see using times i a cia
production of the community when i expo
sits tools apart solution that they for the
sake get this in flames china garden or
on i me likey that
[Music]
and how you see
anyways editors  in belgium function and
increase mobility what he was about there
release of the alpha eat
our way and what you'd expect in and
inflammatory response
moving away from kas der ofzo en wifi or
to do what for in the film blood
vessels anyway
the  wall i like
in it western to arms' and then could
start with coronation he helps he
base blood vessel and healthy some
pictures as it gets fat his seward
look like and us always where exposed' and
honking
growth factors you can really mode of
a change de  morphology and the function
of those you and me and what like with the
cat again how you and our luxury pixelated
inflammatory finality
white lotus an inversions there is so
here you can see any reason iconic
special of 10 of alpha ex  posure what
of that more importantly week and us makes
sense such use reviews it's going to be
men sites and remixes caps suffering the
men actually soot my
parkway and illusion lord law reviews
men sites either floor and
on and and oil berlie attached to one of
the is michael vessels but in this case
of 10 or al at exposure' you see that
more mormons from the here to the jews
and they don't oil sticks and and and the
here what you connection' or function that
die even
start touching groningen  and hostel
extra insurance
out of the outside of the scene physicists
here in red
my mother show is my
wat onesie lizzie what does the word mean
a screen you want to also be able
shortage often watch it beautiful and just like
all to see here
anderslecht je  see you see you become full of chip
tube or and the ilium of erecting
tumor cells from the bottom do you have
any means become your share about law was
ex ely in your even the effects at the
at the tumor cell from the bottom and  and
migrating old put you in will mean
education your connection'
you see you want for it zoomin or
maybe what you can him there kids
chesney very straightforward to quantify
harmony even art in middle
compartment suffering to the source of the invento
reviews
taking it was  there for a long way from
smollett
choose is then for and janice so logical
lord is and again sand in the start off
and huge om
muthert shield is week all about the pot
what where you provider cues for even toe
sprout into the gel channel  in the
middle here is cross-sectional hitman the bin
but you can religion that's garbage o tube
strong wax leave the the gel and there in
shape and pensions boom network of my
profession i surf the [ __ ] alone
and this is or short percent of course
a study that she can see what actually
modify score
promoter producer so and you janice
for jump for looking it
tuber treatment but we can also use it
to my arms los becker
a even en tunnel user van platin  g and
with the place you see zippers and and the
luxury love is like a free line where the
still too few things and our bath in the
middle bert well the shell compartment with
houses extra
100 on i want a private pension from the
top
so hello it  most medically there becomes the
look like what you calling of a want
to be one another tube running of a
freebies 3 in 1 toe and pepper in hotel
and add that via
rio incest not as dessert your skin
compartment or gel with an open access
because it  is the word looks like and in
in real life
in became here in the video itself before you
go toot youth flanking and note the
large apartment of and the rest collagen
in the middle we de holland op telouw
sweet touch that their tasty and what i  a
push that's like you see here's star
rover two tube
tractor and george and assists being the
center and one that and the johnsons the
means
lord jos see you how you kick and a
sharp through an order moment a
lily gets into time  interact me  t
netflix and foil
this is you guys
a website where you come to an old usa
was built up with not also some
before
take and complex free the folks on the
show
margins with is mike confirm at league
got up if you good standards all
purpose in  a video existe in my close
connection' draw tissue tests we
sit and want to once the old voice your
ipad mini one application were relax
the fans r&b for jump on my move
and number and or journal rather is
hyvers safe become noise again so
blood supply  is due to get the media ride
not only not on his site it not
oil filter and just have a blog or
have website so be difficult to type
stable in typing he fashional so be
get closer to the in vivo situation of
this highly refers issue
projection  now hey how to deliver much
from
powder than the vézelay bert and do you get
that here infection not even
extreme die connecten and and and and
complex network on michael vest luxury
with risks into a series  s or the pepper
fruit den praise of start to produce
just every mine first a i really
shell in the functional tee wonder if they
hats wrong
looking into it in the little bit more
the tail bizarre sections the word kat of
the pharaoh is a for  west berlin having
fun with the demarco culture the de the
west charles moore lesson about you the
funeral becomes the atmosphere the december koh
kood become bones means panel you
see the law paint liter is really tennis
know or you know roulette
deliver tissue  and or erroneous is to look
at it using
nice max buy you can see that there is
extreme that time interaction between
the website and the and the pilot itself or something
providing the soon calm structures
of the interaction between the two of kos
prefer websites having he  and
its effective that is what fits but
there is something the piece is there in a
very difficult to
rietepietz suffered and at the time and rosso and
bale day and a certain fact or the dog
system and what you see here  in circle the
formation is alfonso de dance network of
bal apparently like that can take away to
certain discourse behind by peter site
to film otherwise would apply de and
de clean and actually
one of the great things of this is het
of het esf show  you just yet not just
there in whole and is one situational
number so or still have in the
past for wel plate it scalable it
double so you see there is actually
just van deta or or or net pilot
screener idea where you are arguing with
politicians shoes
that there are youtube fact of aspiration
half of the sliver surface rt pff i
now that the facility of amstel live
shows and us occasionally that sandwich
culture and i have close to show that
this is my case small scale and is just
place for  knows who can combine this
with a high and high level biology
wind energy scalable place for a the
really love you to do her full-scale
research of the man is complex issues
that you can imagine what things rich
students  us waste puddings that and
is caused not optimal
restoration of the site not also an
about
information ivory and for family or something
of course one of the real
interesting links lasted and is due
at a box two together
so mission here is to the left  they
terror of social reviews like before you
see that japan
triggers juliet the inflammatory
finality or you and the four him what is
weekend short or so doing in site c
insight a hurricane on the graph middle
vascular bed and other by
putting kimo pulling content even
labor  and choose use that give up and
inflammatory 2 so don't go to
reeleezee choose the weekend recruit
as into that dance network of
marco flasher and or something into the tombs of
the shows that a fast flow he got up
like me this is
and winters and toe  and a lot of interviews
marriage were getting as for your own
discretion the service here jet
but anciaux your channel and brand in the
potential for i will for you another
collective ap  plications
so the weather final and final year of
summer i in that week and my large-scale
porsche our drill michael vestel it you
may draw me to best to tap
i feel they can by the piece of your
choice
and do quiet and large-  scale strien
sunleaf
hope to having you within a little bit
already
overview of how i think we can really
had to be spent or the art of
current issue models and combine the the
best and and and new ways of doing quickly
calster using the best self he ate  your
disposal organize your eyes a lot of time
in hey gary flexible and scalable
platform there are countless to do
the mountain also if there with old xlii having
to move away from the reed out that you
wonder if so
you can do a lot he comes and jump you
can  many do stone spindle frankl
you castle de pear with people just add
and and self love density
jos even varistone set of tools for the
family search earth to get the best
insights into
motto mechanisms barrel somalia te doen
de mijn lui  star help make the best
sizzle
fancy what drugs when good for gets in
the intestines and alfred must number have a
bossche bol influences become home and
grating
root of people doing great science
here in the netherlands where either in your pain
and us but of course  or from orbitals
youtube
number already with leftovers the mean with
cabinets maas and pharma and or so the love
academic and good to various
collaborations that we your ear is taking
part in
so with it he hopes you
inspires you we have look at this
exciting
new  fell into drug development and
i'd like to finish up app
thank you very much for your attention
and i hope you'll enjoy the rest of the
je bent